that do you love doing comedy enough
that you're gonna willing to do it for
free
forever high breath all right
hop retheverse welcome back to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
this is our comic q a series we do
in our facebook group every single week
so if you're watching this on youtube or
listening to it later
go into the description of the show
click join the facebook group so you can
get a part of more of these q and a's
and all the other fun
comedy stuff we have going on in there
but without further ado
there's no need to delay let's welcome
to the show the man of the hour mr kyle
kane everyone
let's give it up for kyle there we are
i like it let's give it up in the vacuum
of the internet
yes i did a i didn't applause sound
effect for you though buddy
all right i know that's good um so i'm
so excited uh first off
thanks for doing this um there's a lot
of fans in this group but then also i'm
just
i'm a personal fan of you in general
and um yeah i've seen you i've seen you
perform in atlanta a few times
and you now coming out with your
upcoming album on july 24th
i think one of my favorite things about
just seeing the
evolution and growth of your comedy
because you started at 99 right in
chicago
yeah yeah okay so it's been great to see
just the evolution of your comedy and
just your
bits grow and grow and something i heard
you say
and um people watching feel free to
comment with questions
for a kyle here but i'm gonna jump in
with a few selfishly myself but
something
i heard you say that really stuck with
me
is that you started to find your voice
when you started
writing jokes that like you were
attached to
and i'd be interested to hear more about
like
that process because finding your voice
is something all comedians and me
i'm just now 10 years in that i feel
like i'm starting to get
like oh maybe if i do a little more
sarcasm it works better but
like still being attached to material is
something i'm trying to work towards how
were you able to do that what was that
process
well i i think with
they say like well there's no official
timeline but they said what is it eight
to ten years is how long it takes to
find your voice and every comic that's
four years
like no i found my voice right now and
then if you stay in it long enough
and get to 10 years you're like oh i was
uh totally wrong i was wrong about
my voice for and when i was four years
in but i think it's the difference that
when you start
you're not really you don't really know
how to process your life and your life's
experiences
into comedy yet but you know how to
write a joke
you know you know you can watch you know
you could watch joke writers you could
watch seinfeld you don't learn anything
about seinfeld's life
from watching seinfeld's comedy but
that's that's joke writing that's what
you need
first right you know you need you need
that skill
and then you could take that skill and
apply it to your actual life
and that i think is where you start to
find your voice because you're like oh
this is a situation that actually
happened to me
at the store or in a relationship so
it's truth
i'm talking my truth but i also have
this skill set of how to take that truth
and put it into a format that is a joke
and that's where i think it starts to
fall in like
like you're saying like you like you
lean into sarcasm more like oh maybe
that's
my style and that's how i convey
the things i want to say not just like i
i look back at my early years of comedy
i know like oh this was a setup and a
punchline it did nothing about
me it was just a joke
and then
you you you figure out that
it's more rewarding but for me i find it
more rewarding to like
oh my my personal experience is like
well we're laughing at my personal
experiences
not punching down but like i get to talk
about myself i think that's what voices
you like
but then again i love mitch hedberg and
that guy never talked about his life at
all
yeah and that your line on your first
album where it's like you wake you ever
wake up
and pretty much it's like wake up and
believe in yourself like that was almost
like a spark for you
that kind of you started to use that as
kind of a jumping off point to start
building material what was it about that
line
that really kind of opened up the next
level of your comedy
i think because i thought my life was in
the in the best most humorous way pretty
stupid
uh you know and
there's no uh there's hardly any
originality the boy the whole the dumb
guy
the dumb guy routine that's worked in uh
sitcoms
from the dawn of television you know
the old sloppy boy i'm look at this
dumbo guy
but if i was talking about specific
situations in my life you can't take
that away from me you can't tell me it's
hack
if it's at my actual life if me
you know if me walking through the
grocery store drunk holding a 12-pack
balance and frozen pizzas on it
just having a good time even though
that's
typical dumb guy [ __ ] that's my that's
what i did on a saturday night
and that was funny to me that i was
still happy in the midst of that
being my lonely saturday night but yeah
it was
i was realizing that also i had i was
relating to a lot more people of like
that was maybe that was death of the
party that was 2009
but so that means those jokes were in
the works in the mid-aughts
which was plenty of people that spent
ridiculous amounts of money to go to
liberal arts colleges thinking that
you're
in your right to pursue your dream and
then all you got was debt
and not a career that was if you were
lucky
maybe distantly related to what you
really wanted to do
so i think that material
struck with a struck a chord with a lot
of people that were like
oh yeah i don't think we're gonna get
the life we wanted to
even though we just spent you know tens
of thousands of dollars on an education
that was worthless and now we're in debt
which
we're seeing more of now and it's not i
don't think it's barely even funny
anymore because now the cost of
education
has skyrocketed compared to the cost
compared to inflation and now it's now
it's a total [ __ ] show right he's making
fun of it before it was just a little
bit of a [ __ ] show no it's a whole
business
but i think it related i think the
laughs i got
from that was like it was maybe it was
funny but also that people
related to it and that's you know when
you watch a comedian you're like
people love jim gaffigan because he
talks about food guess what everybody
has to eat to stay alive you're going to
relate to food relationships everybody
gets lonely they want to
you know you know regardless of i think
you know gender or sexuality still
there's still
some inherent need to be with somebody
so the idea of a relationship
is still relatable to most people on
earth
so being a you know
30 something early 30s loser
with student loan debt and a pointless
day job
related to a lot of people and that
self-awareness i guess is what
translates it starts with like being
aware of who you are and how you got
there
and then maybe like letting your
material bloom from that is what
seemingly more personal it's almost like
the more universal
the material becomes
yeah i mean you know you never want to
be disingenuous i mean like that's
that's you end up pricing yourself out
of the market
if you do a good enough job complaining
about how shitty your life is and being
broke and having shitty day jobs
well then i got rewarded with a career
in comedy well guess what i'm not
broke and i don't have a shitty day job
anymore i'm not going to go and
act like i am because then that just
turns into larry the cable guy
and it's just a caricature of like uh oh
man i'm only making nine dollars down at
the pizza hut tonight no that's not
the truth of my situation so
i gotta try and make more relatable
material now about
i mean still i'm still [ __ ] but
what is that decision for you because
that's something a lot of comics also
have to like think about when they are
pursuing comedy is like
okay balancing a day job and doing
comedy at night and you were working
closed captioning
for tv and then like you basically quit
your job
and recorded that album we were talking
about it almost seems like you had
almost like a
a moment where you were just like no i'm
going for this now
yeah i mean i i did move
to los angeles to be a comedian
i didn't move to be any other thing
you know it's it's i it's
i i still like los angeles and it's
great that you there are these other
options to like oh maybe somebody wants
you to write for tv or maybe somebody
wants to act but i wanted to be a
stand-up i moved there
for that and i'd gotten a
manager and i got an agent and i told
him like
but i still i mean i'm from the midwest
i don't do like the
if you just i don't believe in the
secret or any of that [ __ ] like if you
just dream it and will it it'll happen
it's like no
you work you just you work that's what
you do
in life and then you want to be a
comedian that's great
you do that after you work so
when i was recording that album and
gonna quit
my job because i had an agent i'm like i
need
you to tell me that you can book me
enough work because even though i had a
crummy day job at least i knew i was
going to get this much money a week and
i could pay my bills
so i am i am very married to security a
lot of the times
which is not great when you're pursuing
your dreams like well but i put this
i'm getting health insurance from my day
job
i uh so yeah that was what happened like
i'm like all right i'm gonna put this
album out i'm gonna go
like i need you to book me wherever i
just want the work
i don't care i'll if even if it's shitty
i just want the work i bet summer
it was ten years ago this summer was
anniversary i got
all my cds i was i put them in i had a
pickup truck with a shell on the back so
i went out on tour and i was
sleeping in that some of the nights and
just selling cds like
i'll go i'll take all the lessons i
learned from punk rock and diy
and just go sell the albums yourself and
be so yeah that was it i was like i'm
gonna i need to work i can't do this
like
stay in between jobs and hope it comes
together thing i need to know that i
think yeah i love that diy approach i
mean that's
that's what i'm all about but what it
took me probably
because i just like self-produced my own
special and i i'd self-produce my own
tour last year like i'm all about diy
but it took me probably seven or eight
years into comedy
to stop being like but why isn't that
club booking me or why why can't i get
on that show you know all that like self
negative talk that just perpetually goes
through comedian's head like how
how are you able to overcome that yeah
yeah that is kind of sometimes the catch
of diy
is uh it's it it can be diy up to a
point where if you're doing something
that's good desirable other people will
want to help you
do it yourself but if nobody ever wants
to help you
do it yourself maybe what you're doing
isn't that good
and that's some of the self-awareness of
like
i'll go out and make as many
opportunities for myself
you know but you know worried about
clubs i don't care about you know
clubs booking me but i'm like just any
kind of recognition even if it's
i mean you get it right away in stand-up
you get people to laugh
so you know something's working
so outside of people laughing did you
get booked on another show
like that i knew there was no
you know harder they come harder they
fall type thing the faster you rise the
faster you fall
so i'll whatever show i was on i'm like
i need to be the best comedian on that
show
no that's an arbitrary statement but i
just need to do well
not at the expense of somebody else and
not punching down i just need to do good
on that show because if i do good on
that show
i'm talking about when i move to la then
people that are at that show might book
another show
that's just a little bit better than the
one i was just on
it's not like i did great at this hotel
lobby basement bar
now i'm gonna be on the tonight show no
that's not how it works
you do great on the hotel basement bar
show and then maybe you get booked
at a bar show that has a few more people
into it that like comedy
and then you get they have better comics
on that show those better comics see you
do well and they tell people
on another show so you just kind of
slowly zigzag upwards
and that's how you guarantee the quality
of it
like i know i got what i got because i
earned it not because of a fluke not
because of
you know you can schmooze all you want
you can make all the you can network all
you want and you can i've seen people
schmooze their way on to good shows and
then
they bomb because they didn't put the
work in first i'd rather be asked to be
on the show than ask somebody to be
honest
i love that visual representation like
zigzagging your way to where you want to
get just being patient appreciating the
process
and focusing on what you can control you
can control whether or not
you're putting in the work to kill on
stage that then someone sees and wants
to book
it's focusing on what you can control
and not some like validation
well and like yeah like you're saying
that's the you know it's quality control
and that's how
you know you keep your own ego in check
because i know that i
earned what i got in hustle i didn't
schmooze i didn't
network i earned what i got so
if a club didn't book me i'm not gonna
worry i'm gonna
where i'm at i know i earned it and if
it's time for me to go to the next level
i will know i have earned that next
level
if i'm not making it to the next level
maybe i didn't earn that yet maybe i'm
not putting the work in i blame myself
first before blaming anybody
else and what is always jealousy
is [ __ ] talking but right still is there
still jealousy for you
oh all the time yeah wow but it doesn't
it doesn't do me any good
because you know people get netflix
specials people get
you know and it's like all right
[Laughter]
and what what am i going to do right
about it man it doesn't it it it exists
jealousy always exists and i'll [ __ ]
about it around people i know i can
[ __ ] about it around right but then the
the end result is like what are we gonna
what i have a career i tell jokes for a
living
what why why i got the thing
you know yeah and right you know what's
what's popular isn't always what's good
i mean we can we know who the president
is right now
like we don't have to go political with
it but what's popular
isn't what's good all the time sometimes
people that get a netflix special i'm
like hell yeah they should have that
special
and sometimes there's people i'm like
all right well that's the temperature of
the world right now
that's what people want and okay i'm not
that i'm not what they want so that's
okay
have you tried to get one on netflix
have you tried that route
i was on i did the stand-ups it was like
the
half-hour ones and then and to be honest
i this
special that's coming out now i did a
showcase and i
had you know my representatives asked
people from networks to come out
and uh come see this new hour and uh
it didn't go great so i
did not earn that next step
i had people come out and i didn't i
didn't have a great show
and that's on me i should have been more
prepared i should have uh
been more focused through the set i've
found myself wandering thinking like oh
it's like a road gig where i can kind of
dick around no that's not i i made bad
choices
and it resulted in uh people saying no
to this for uh you know to being an
on-air or a streaming
video special so but that i mean that's
that's very um inspiring to hear someone
at your level
even be like you know what i dropped the
ball on this it wasn't some network that
had a conspiracy against me you know i
just didn't do what i needed to do to
earn it i mean that that takes a lot of
self-awareness
and like humidity humility
what a great word
[Laughter]
of all the words to stumble on that's
the one
[Laughter]
i possess a great deal
[Laughter]
that was the perfect word yeah the hot
breath humility that's what we're gonna
call it
hilarious yeah man i i beefed it i could
have had a better set and i didn't and i
was like well this was the
wrong night to have a crummy set but
here we are
but we're seeing people like um
even like hannibal burris um who and
mark norman and sam morrell who are like
self-releasing or self-producing
specials
like did you think about going that
route or are you just like um
i'll just i'll just throw the album out
there and get spins on sirius and all
that
yeah you know those those lucrative
spotify
checks oh but sirius can be quite so
serious is the one yeah yeah sears can
be some nice income
well that's why after somebody was uh
after i got no's
you know on all that stuff
i just i decided like why nobody needs
i mean right now where does comedy get
consumed outside of like a netflix
you listen to it why
do i want to put the pressure on not
only
financing or getting trying to find
people to finance
and i hate to you know sound like the
you know the
uh liberal uh criticism du jour but like
who needs another straight white dude
walking around on stage with a
microphone
if if it's good comedy it the audio will
suffice
the visual is just a component that
people
they look at once and then it's still
they listen to it
so i'm like i'll go back to an album i
don't know i
i am you know doing some animation with
it i
put some effort into animation that was
the effort i wanted to fully animate it
with different stuff with different
styles with like having different
animators come in and take
a bit and kind of do it like waking
lifestyle
oh that's cool each section like each
section would just have a different
animator
doing whatever they wanted not animated
kyle on stage because then that's the
same thing i tried to avoid
so i have some of that i have some small
bits of that coming out
and i told i told one network i'm like
listen although like
the comedy central did say like oh we'd
like to do a new special with you and i
was like well
how about instead of taping it let's
just
save the money that you would spend
producing
a live special and spend it on animation
and they weren't they
didn't bite on that idea
but i like that yeah i like you thinking
outside of the
the box out of the form because it is
there's so many specials now it is kind
of like how can we stand out
and what unique spin can we put on it
yeah and it's you know it's all going to
get chopped up into clips and
uh what can you share through a youtube
video and so
what people put that on and minimize it
anyway just to listen to it so why
spend all the money on the visual if
that's not
and i'm not going to spend my i wasn't
going gonna spend my own money on the
visual aspect of it
yeah have you seen have you seen
hannibal's or any clips of it or
anything no i heard i heard he messed
around
and did like not not in a bad way but
like did all weird stuff with it oh it's
wild i haven't seen it yet
yeah it's a trip for sure did you start
with him in chicago
he we didn't really overlap much i had
left he was around a little bit
right before i left i moved in 2003.
gotcha
he was around right towards the end and
then i remember
coming back and somebody's like
man hannibal got real good like hannibal
was like
you see everybody at open mic everybody
sucks exactly
oh stop it was like yeah hannibal got a
real good one cannibal
yeah and now here we are yeah
and it's great because that guy doesn't
think he only does things the way he
wants to
and that's awesome yeah it really is it
really is inspiring
to see comics yeah doing things in their
own voice in their own way
yeah so let's let's get into
um some of the fan joe uh fan jokes
fan questions here um
we actually had a few people that jumped
in at the beginning because they're at
work
they like jumped in to post a question
and then left they were like i just want
to post this i got to go back to work
like well fair enough there's people i
i've had
there's a there's a comic named chase
bonnie who was like watching one
um it may have been the dan soder one
but he was like watching like from
the bathroom of his job he was just like
it's funny to see i'm not gonna have a
job for too long
it's hilarious uh so let's see uh
kyle groom jumped in here first
oh and he actually said i'll be making
balloon animals for kids during this
interview so i'll ask this now
okay um let's see
i have heard you say paraphrasing i'll
take a good two minute joke and make it
into a mediocre five minute joke
i think it's great i just want to know
your process on how to do that
uh i've always likened it to uh
you know again it goes back to like when
you like writing a joke
that's about brevity and you know
you know how effective you use your
words
but i wind up i prattle on as evident in
this
interview that i get i i get into
telling stories and telling yarns and
that's
that's less on brevity and more on
[ __ ] where it's like all right you
know you tell a story on friday night
and people laugh at it at a party then
you tell it on saturday night to a new
group of people
and the colors get a little brighter and
the measurements get a little bit larger
and you you know you start getting
you know irish storytelling as it's
called
and uh by next weekend now that
five-minute story is a 15-minute story
because you got new punch lines and then
oh wait
this old guy over here was looking at me
real weird would i
well i did it and that's what oh so you
mean like
it'll start off as like something like
small and basic and then you start
looking for details to then build the
joke with
yeah i mean that's like if you i mean if
you know any kind of
when you enjoy uh reading literature or
something it's like well you could say
i walked up to the house or you could
say i walked up
the narrow sidewalk to the house or you
could say i walked up the narrow
sidewalk lined with tulips towards the
house
i walked up a narrow sidewalk lined with
tulips towards the orange house with the
blue awnings i thought that color choice
was weird
last time i saw blue with orange was the
bears and i don't even like chicago
bears football but man
let me tell you about when they won the
super bowl the super bowl shuffle you
ever hear that that's a stupid song
there you go that's all i mean by it
that's
you can make it's your it's
you can veer off any way you want
and make a joke out of any angle you
want it's your story
now you've got to pay attention am i
losing the audience or are they getting
confused by the end but
you can talk about any detail you want
about a joke i went to the store what's
the name of the store what does the
store specialize in
was the clerk that checked you out have
a weird haircut when you
went to the store like there's all those
things
all those details that you can make
little jokes about
i got a bunch of stories that hate to do
the plug on the new album but there's
no please do yeah it's an hour well it's
an hour and 45 minutes in the last
hour first hour is the hour i've been
doing the run last 45 minutes i think
it's like three stories
so what
three stories over 45 minutes that's
incredible
but but it's it really isn't though like
you watch a movie that's two hours long
and it's like
if it's just a romance boy meets girl
boy loses girl boy gets girl back
there you just told the story now how
can a movie be two hours about that
same way as any joke can be that long
but for that movie to be captivating for
that long
is where the real craft comes in and
yeah i mean
someone can get on stage and tell three
stories that span 45 minutes but
to make them consistently funny and
engaging
and entertaining that's where the skill
set comes in that's where
i feel like you're not giving yourself
enough credit that you just rambled off
all these details about walking up to
the house
as if everyone has this reflex to be
like oh but then the blue awning and
then i
associate that with chicago bears it's
like you know i mean there's
there's there's a skill set it seems
you've been able to hone that is now
just like a reflex of
this happened but now i can put it
through all these filters
that add details and embellishments to
really bring it to life
well that that skill set develops when
you only have 10 minutes material and
you're given a half hour spot
oh that's great yeah good good
storytelling tips that was something a
few people are asking about stories too
though so um
yeah we'll um we'll go more in any joke
any joke you could throw one more added
detail into it and get another 30
seconds out of that
i mean it's harder to do when you're
doing open mics and you only have five
minutes to work with because you want
laughs per minute you want to get
you're not going to go tell one five
minute preps
you know set up for a punchline at the
end of your open mic set everybody's
like what are you doing you're wasting
my time
so it's hard to develop that when you're
only doing open mics
you really it's it's really only comes
like when you do get longer spots you
get a little
more time to kind of stretch out when
you're on stage
but you mentioned this earlier in the
interview is like you first learned
the basics of writing you first learned
like how to even write a joke before you
try
to start embellishing and building up
all these huge stories you kind of
started with the rules
and then you can break them once you
know them type deal
yeah yeah that's yeah so like an open
bike city
yeah yeah you still can't just go like
well i'm interesting here let me tell
you about my life
now you got to have yep
there's got to be howard hughes could be
boring as [ __ ] to listen to you don't
know if the guy didn't know how to
tell a story who cares about his
accomplishment seems boring
and then you've got a guy who works at
it you know works at an ice cream parlor
who could be fascinating to listen to
because the guy knows how to tell a
story so
nice so let's get into uh
the next one lee hudson he's actually uh
he's actually in the uk
um and he asks what differences have you
found
when you've performed in the uk any
observations on how the audience
receives you
i i mean i haven't performed there a lot
but i'll say they
they seem to reward
the cleverness and the concise writing
that i was mentioning
not so much the uh rambling storyteller
thing
especially ooh man ireland if you
perform in ireland
you better get on it quick oh yeah they
do not
suffer any meandering [ __ ] over
there they need
everybody's already funny in ireland
like i did comedy festival there was
sean patton and we're like why
we didn't even know why they were having
a comedy festival because everybody
there was already funny
like even the guy at the border like
checking the passport when you land at
the airport
which i've had troubles with with
legal issues with canada it's a story
that's on the new album
but uh so landing in ireland and having
the guy like oh do you have paperwork
for this festival i'm like i don't
they just told me he's like ah i'm just
[ __ ] with you
comedy festivals they have fun and they
gave them like how you wearing a uniform
and you're just [ __ ] around
like like but like even easy stuff like
the guy driving us from the airport to
the hotel is just yelling at somebody
for stopping at a yellow light
he's like go yellow is just another
shade of green
hilarious that's
that's concise that's quick and so yeah
i'd go up there and start like
well anyway i was hanging out like no
get to it they want
quicker stuff but interesting you know
in england it was definitely
i think they they seem to value
cleverness
uh even if it's not like and i don't
want to say this the
wrong way well worded uh like there's
salesmanship involved in comedy
and i think cleverness is good but then
sometimes salesmanship like
if you've done comedy a long enough time
you're like i know this is a hack bit
but you're selling it well and so some
of that stuff
i think in rowdy rooms like they'll
reward
well-dressed hat comedy
because they're rowdy they want to party
you know and then they're drunk but
yeah like that and you you to find out
what references that you don't realize
are in your set that are so uniquely
american
that's always a weird one you like go
through it like oh they may not have
this
store or this and that but then you just
try and mention something about health
care and you're like oh yeah
that's actually much more of a developed
system over here
yeah exactly yeah so
nice but you got to be on you got to be
on your game when you're performing over
there especially especially as an
american i think they're excited to uh
drag drag your ass
all right let's get a um
another one here from scott leibowitz
we got a um a story
question again he asked um was your bit
about the couch party that the cop
crashed a true story
yes yeah that was uh
now again there's an example of how
for some reason and there is a bit about
how was a party about somebody buying a
new couch or something like i
that had nothing to do with the story
but it just turned into a bit about like
how do you get a couch people just buy
couches and [ __ ]
that became part of that story even
though it's not
it's just a detail that there was a
couch in the apartment of adults
and i made a one-off like i don't know
it might have been a party because
somebody bought a new couch
and then i felt like yeah people at some
point you start buying furniture instead
of finding it
there that's a whole new bit but yeah
that was real about the cop coming down
from upstairs because a guy died
yeah that part's real what is it like
being that's something
i want to get better at and i think a
lot of comics strive for is like
oh this happened in real life now how
can i translate to stage to where it's
laugh laugh laugh laugh
laugh so it's like that that happens to
you
and then what is the process for then
starting to hone that into like a bit
that is actually consistently funny
it's a lot of it is you know it's not
always
outward we're you know you think a story
has to be
the actual facts and the pacing of the
events that happened have to be funny
and whereas
again there's nothing like the fact that
a cop
came downstairs and had a nonchalant
attitude
and we were like all the events were
funny in that but then
okay being panicky on a porch because
you're you know got a bunch of weed and
underage drinking and stuff
cool add details otherwise somebody
could tell that same story but yeah
we're out there
we're all [ __ ] up and this cop came by
and he like didn't care
that's that story that's that's what
that story is i thought it was way more
funny to think about
that there was somebody dead upstairs
and we were just
celebrating life not knowing that that's
the opposite of it
like death existed right there and how
miniscule we felt in the moment like
that's what i wanted to focus on is
everybody's feelings
and that's the where the story comes in
is like internalize
all the minutia again i always use the
go to the store example because it's
easy but you know like i went to the
store
how were you feeling when you were at
the store how
what mood were you in what music was
playing that made your mood that way
or changed your move like that's how the
story becomes
funny is all the minutia that you get to
internalize and process yourself there's
you know the physical events don't have
to be funny
you know what are you processing why are
you buying what you're buying at the
store
what weird combo of things are you
buying at the store
there's nothing to do with what happened
in the parking lot of the store it's
just
all more [ __ ] to throw on
instead of writing a brand new joke
about some
entirely separate occurrence in your
life like no i went to the store
here's 20 minutes about it and then are
you
are you writing it all out are you going
on stage and just
telling it from memory it's usually
i try to do enough sets i can't get into
the new york mentality of doing like
four sets in a night i don't
i don't like myself enough to do four
sets in the night
i don't want to hear myself i don't like
doing two sets especially like doing a
comedy club after two sets in a night
i'm like i don't want to hear my own
voice
for another 24 hours but uh
but like usually back you know back in
normal times
about every night i'd have a set or
every other night
and you know you tell it and you're like
i have
i have the bullet points written down so
that way i'm not married to any
structure
but i'm like you want to get to this
then to this then to this
and if something really unique or fun
happens i'm pretty bad about recording
sets and listening back to them
but if something really good like funny
like as soon as i get off stage i try to
make a note on my phone or write down
like hey
remember this line that you said so that
way it's not
glued in structurally but it's floating
around remember this other funny thing
that happened when you told this story
and then by the end of the week you got
five more bullet points to that story
that can float and move around and
it'll they'll find their place
eventually and then you go
headline or feature somewhere where you
got more time to tell that story
and everything kind of starts finding
its place you're doing a weekend at a
club so you've got five shows
and everything can start falling into
place after that
it's not very regimented it's not it's
not great advice it's real loose and
sloppy and i forget things and
it's not my methods aren't good man
that's what i love interviewing like
comics who've been doing it 20 30 years
and
it's like they know the secret but it is
like i mean it works eventually
like i've figured out a way for it to
hobble together eventually there's no
like scientific system to what most of
us comics do
i'm sure every comic said it but that
like no it's repetition
yes just do your reps go
do another set and the best bombing
oh man it's still i still bomb
and it it is such a weird
like it feels good to know that it can
still happen
yeah because if you don't if you don't
bomb after a while
you're not challenging yourself you're
not trying
i like that well i know this i know this
formula works and i'll give people a
formula people get [ __ ] sick of a
formula i'll tell you that
or maybe people don't maybe you know who
am i gonna tell somebody who's doing a
stadium
who's a comedian doing a stadium and
their formula
sold that many tickets and i'm out like
i got that i got to do a 200 seater
because i love challenging the audience
what is what is like your most recent
unforgettable bomb
all right man well now with all this
stuff
hasn't been like right yeah
i i kind of i was in a bad mood at a
show in chicago where i was doing two
nights
at dahlia hall and the first night i was
there just i wasn't on my game and i was
like
i realized the material i was doing had
a negative slant to it
and i wasn't delivering this negative
material in a fun way
i was delivering it and like in another
thing
and that's not fun and that's not
people were not it wasn't a bomb but i i
ended the show going like oh i
it wasn't a good mood you know and
people laugh but the comedy can be
sinister
you know and i don't that's not what i
want to do i don't want to do
you know sinister know-it-all kind of
like
let me tell you how the world works
right my again
you know what it was it wasn't in my
voice
you can write material even 20 years in
that you think is good jokes but if it's
not in your voice you'll tell
the audience it's like oh that's not why
we like
that's not what's interesting about kyle
you know it's like if bill burr was like
you know what i love my baby
and he could write a great joke about
loving his kid and his audience he'd be
like
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] on us we like it when you [ __ ] on
us and tell us that the world
sucks even if the joke's good or if john
mulaney did the opposite you know what
kids are [ __ ] stupid let me tell you
about i'd be like oh no john
no right why we like john fellaini
so as much as i thought it was good
material it wasn't in
my uh my voice and so
and then in la la i bomb a lot
like here's 10 minutes of new stuff oh
it works in my
precious little alternative rooms but
then i'll go to the improv or the
laugh factory comedy store get my ass
handed to me
all right but you gotta do it on board
so many comics
do like find their comfort zone and then
just keep hitting ground balls to that
comfort zone
yeah i don't that's not what's fun about
comedy to me right like like i want to
be good at it but i also want to enjoy
it like you can get good at something
because you figured it out and then
you're bored just because you're good at
it doesn't mean you're not going to get
bored i don't want to get bored with
comedy i don't have to find something
else to do
i can't do anything else joel i don't
have other skills i gotta i gotta keep
doing this
oh you're in it now you're too far in i
mean me ten years in i'm like there's
there's no going back
like it's it's a lifestyle now yeah
unless you got pro lighting and pro gear
for the podcast thing i can't even get
that together
well i have i need this more than you do
this this is my
come up i need this you're yeah you're
already there you release specials
you're releasing this new album i'm
still like hey guys remember
keep up with me so well at least at
least
there's uh at least we're running out of
comedians
at least the world is short on comics
what
mark norman was saying on here he hopes
it thins the herd a lot like all this
quarantine he's like i hope it thins the
herd
get the weak ones out of the way
does it well just driving them into
tick-tock
right we just saw you're on now
that's a management deal they're like
you should be on it i'm like i don't
know what to do
what i don't even have i don't even have
the physical
app i send them they're like we'll just
put
your words up there and we just need
videos of your face i'm like i'll send
you videos in my face
i don't know what happens on tick tock
yeah i'm not on there but i saw you post
it
huh yeah i was like all right here it is
if you think this is gonna
do something then go but it's not gonna
do [ __ ]
so is is is that how because i mean i
don't i don't have any representation or
anything i mean is that
is that where the game is right now
where like your representation is like
hey we would really like you to do this
make a tick tock
that's the next thing i mean is that is
that the rapport in the relationship i
just don't know
that with my current management
yeah i have new management there and
they know my hesitation and all that
stuff
well we'll do it for you just give us
this like all it needs i'm like i don't
even understand it works like just give
us a video of your face
but then your bit will play in the
background and i'm like
all right because i'm
uh pretty much against the idea what is
it it's just an information
farm for for china spots or something
yeah i
tell you so as long as i don't know what
you're getting out of me i don't i
barely
even use the thing i you know it's not
on my phone i had it and it was just
like
just it was just a lot of boobs dancing
and i was like all right
i mean cool but
again i'm also 43. it's
i'm not supposed to understand it but
that's why i didn't know like why
management would be like
kyle will do viral videos on tick tock i
just don't even see where the tran
where it translates you know joel
neither do i
okay neither do i but if they have
designs
if it means the comedy gets out there
that's all i want that's all that
matters comedy gets out there within
my realm of control cool
if it if it's a flop who gives a [ __ ]
it's tick tock it's like 12 year olds
and cam girls if i
fail on that that's was meant to be yes
i'm fine with that it's not something
you're looking to earn
as we'll say i i
do i am grateful that i got to come up
before
social media right before just right
before so i got to see what it was like
right before and like i was saying that
youtube stars i'm glad i'm glad they're
millionaires
i don't think it's good comedy but
it doesn't have to be for me i'm like i
said i'm 43 if you're
i don't i shouldn't be a hit with 15
year olds right
i shouldn't not i should not be popular
with teens
i'm not gonna try you want to put it on
tick-tock you want to put it up there
go for it but i know my audience is
30 and up bald dudes
tattoos and musical instruments they
don't play anymore
that's what my comedy is for all right
well let me uh
let me get to a few more here and we can
um we start to land this
plane um we really give shorter answers
too
we appreciate your time oh dude sean
patton went i mean
if you give him a if you give him a
comedy topic he will go
so it's that's you that's that's the
prime example of
why of of what's good isn't always
what or what's popular isn't always
what's good
is that sean patton should be uh
the biggest stand-up comedian uh working
some people are getting what they
deserve
like i know sam jay is getting a netflix
special yeah that's one of the people
where i'm like
yes okay put her up there
yes but sean patton
it's it's uh i think that's criminal
that he is not
more well-known oh i mean i remember
seeing him in atlanta like i watched
several of his shows in a row when he
last time he was at punchline and like
every single show was completely
different
and absolutely hilarious and i'm just i
was like watching it like i don't even
know what's happening but he's murdering
and it's hilarious
and each show was like just a unique
experience i'm just like how
you know well i look at him as an
influence of like
that's like when you let your
imagination
take control like when you just get some
sort of bridle
on your imagination so you can just hold
the reins and then let it like
we're going to go into weird corner like
he'll start bits like the bit
that's a bit about how childbirth
sometimes gives their mothers
orgasms all right man
let me see you let me see you do this
let me
i love the challenge that you just
created for yourself
yeah telling a group of strangers this
fact
and then you're going to try and make
comedy out of it yeah
it's so good yeah he talked about
uh you're actually your bit actually
getting pulled over by the police on a
bicycle
because someone had asked about
physicality and he used that exact
that joke as an example of you being
physical on stage and like painting the
picture without even saying anything
well yeah you know me and my mime work
i love that god i love comedians we're
like kyle kane is brilliant and then
you're like yeah
cool i can pull off 20-minute stories
that are hilarious beginning middle and
end
cool i mean pretended to ride a bike on
stage
give me a goddamn oscar
but to see the evolution of that joke
because there's like an older version of
that joke online as well
where you're saying the joke and it's a
little bit more edge
it's a little bit more anger and you're
not acting out anything and then to see
the final product i think you're at a
festival or something
to where you have the act out your
pacing's a lot slower
you like it but to see the evolution of
that joke you know i mean
it's fun it's fun and there is a skill
involved with paying a picture
with just a microphone it's
the irony of like getting somebody like
you get these festivals that want to
tape
like you know just for laughs and we're
going to tape and it's just this kind of
papered funneled in audience that isn't
even
ready for comedy and that's what gets
the most views on youtube is you eating
[ __ ]
in front of people who some of them
english is their second language like
there's one thing that keeps getting
aired is when i was in amsterdam
and like the whole audi like english is
their third language
and i'm like this is the worst there is
to get the most like to be the example
of look at them like
but here's this one where i did it in
front of 10 people and it's great
and that one doesn't get a good 20 years
can't control it so oh we've got um
we've got one that's about your joke
development this is actually from chase
bonnin
who says um the i heart squirters joke
how long did it take you to get i love
comedy by the way
it's like we're talking like it's a fine
wine
the i heart squirters joke mr canaan a
little
context on that one that was a slogan on
a t-shirt of somebody in the front row
not a personal belief but that's what he
said um
how long did it take you to be different
to squirters how long did it take you
to get that album worthy and he's asking
this because that was his buddy that was
wearing that shirt
well album worthy i mean
when was that show i'll look at my
calendar right
now because that show where the guy was
wearing that shirt was maybe
three weeks before i take that special
whoa
i'm gonna look i want to look around i'm
looking right now hold on
because that was that was that was taped
in may may 16.
let me see april i'm gonna find i'm
gonna find it right now
yeah please do
hold on yeah i think that was uh
probably just a few weeks beforehand
that's awesome uh that that that went
down
what a small world that that was his
friend that was wearing that shirt and
now he's sitting on a q a
with you i believe that was uh
was that uh i'm sorry it was uh
it was not new orleans lafayette
louisiana which i just had to put off
oh yeah i i was there last year
you're in lafayette old jp yeah leonard
yeah one of jp leonard show you know
what now i look like an idiot because i
cannot find exactly when that went down
because i'm looking for when i was there
and i really did think it was right
before that
it's no worries at all yeah so i i
apologize for getting people excited
about that
but it's something you had to throw
together fairly quickly
because if it's just a few weeks you can
do anything a guy a guy
wore a i heart squirters t-shirt
what did i have to do other than report
back
report a guy that a guy wore that on a
shirt
yeah that's true that's all i had to do
i didn't there's no
all i said was i was the guy wearing i
heart
squirters that's
all that's what happened
that guy was the guy was the bit that
was
journalism on my part
no offense to the guy wearing the i
heart squirter shirt no i hope his love
continues
so um yeah maybe we could just kind of
jump through a few
and just kind of give them some peppered
answers um
yeah this one and you've already touched
on this a little bit but uh scott
porteous actually says he saw you
in um where'd it go oh he saw you in
winnipeg and it was a treat
so that's cool oh man
was that a duff on duff's uh
show last summer r.i.p john duff
anyway was that a question uh no his
question was
uh what anywhere i talked about
storytelling tips but are there any more
i guess he says what tips do you have
for anyone who
takes a storytelling approach to comedy
i i mean i mean for practice try to make
something boring interesting
you know now just see if like
you gotta go mow the lawn all right
start start writing down details about
mowing the lawn see if you can make that
into a joke
you can do that then you know you could
take any situation
tell a story about it again it doesn't
have to be
the outcome of the the physical outcome
of what happened
in the story you know it doesn't have to
be an epic tale it could be just
something
pathetic and mundane and that's what's
interesting about it
and what do you this can kind of tag on
brody blair's question but his is pretty
much like when um
how do you write when you feel like
nothing is happening in your life
how do you find motivation to write
i don't i mean i don't like force it
some people can go and sit
and write jokes and i don't
i can't do that i mean if nothing's
happened in my life i try to make my
life more interesting i'd try to do
i mean i'm not like an exercise guy like
bike ride but just anything like
get the blood flow and get like feel
like
mental health mental and physical health
uh
plays a lot into
for me to do comedy yeah me too like if
i'm
you know i don't write you know i might
write about being bummed out but i only
find things
that i can make things entertaining when
i'm in a good mood if i'm bummed out i'm
not really
in the mood to create comedy i'll write
down details while i'm bummed out and
then maybe later it'll turn but
yeah yeah mental mental and physical
health like even just
go take a walk go ride a bike get some
blood moving through you
it's counteracts uh you know
any kind of depressive qualities you
might have
you know it's not it's not a cure all by
any means but
that kind of stuff if nothing's
happening go make something happen go
move around go
try and try and improve your quality of
life
is that your similar strategy because
barrack kyle's asking about overcoming
writer's block is that how you overcome
writer's block is just like go do
things
every time usually about once a year
i'll get to the point where i'm like oh
i stripped out that gear
of comedy like i can't write more comedy
i don't i lost it and that's going to
happen that's writer's block whatever
you want to call it
writer's block to me always is like i
sat down to write and i can't write
anything
i don't ever do that that's not my
process but it's like
i haven't written a new bit that i like
i've written bits where i'm like i try
to force them or try to force something
to be funny that's not
once a year with this this year being
the exception with everything that's
going on
but then i'll just have a month-long
streak of just eating [ __ ] on stage with
material that i don't believe in and
trying to make work and it just won't
work and uh
just have faith that it will go away
you don't you don't get to know how long
it's gonna last
but eventually it does go away
eventually you write
one joke that is funny and you like it
and then you feel
good about that joke and because you
feel good you write more jokes because
you're in a better mood because that one
work
and it just takes a while sometimes to
get to that
there's no i don't have any proven
technique
it's just man ride it out it sucks but
ride it out
yeah that that's something we all need
to hear even like a comic at your level
is like
we all go through those ruts but you
you've got to keep
keep moving forward like don't stop like
just
keep getting the reps in and you'll
break out of it eventually yeah
well you get caught up trying to live
the lifestyle of this the
the person you create on stage like oh
i'm a boozin
do whatever kind of guy it's like yeah
but sometimes
to keep writing about that lifestyle you
can't be that lifestyle you know
you can't maybe sometimes you got to
take a week off and
as i i i don't like jogging but as i
call it take your tits out for a shake
you know go run around and you know
shake off the cobwebs
yeah go and go take your jugs out for a
jiggle and get uh
get get uh dust off the cobwebs
because uh yeah every night of boozing
and being in a permanent state of
hangover and drunk
uh as much as all your creative heroes
may have put off that they live that
lifestyle
secretly there's moments where they got
up early and
had a cup of coffee and had some clarity
and got to work you know
so yeah your word choice
is it's just so precise do you when
you're like writing a joke
to punch it up will you say like hey
maybe there's a funnier word there
because i'll see your words even just
getting a laugh just because of what it
is
oh always yeah there's so many words to
choose from
and i am always spawn the rut i i
curse too much and i get
sick of my son there's you could say the
same sentence
10 different ways with with a thesaurus
and wine and i don't want to ever do it
to sound pretentious it's just like
again it's like well you got different
shirts you can put on every day well
you like you know that's why not why why
not change it up just
because then it's fun to say then it's
like it's like you're more excited to
say a bit because you got a new silly
word to put in i love it
i love it and uh the final yeah the
final one here
is uh rock allen just asking if you've
ever had any negative blowback from a
bit
um oh sure yeah
all the time i'm one i'm gonna say all
the time but
um yeah i mean i i've
spouted off about some uh
gun control issues that i wasn't
educated on before i started spouting
off about stuff
but uh and plenty of stuff i talk out my
ass
you know about a lot of things
and uh sometimes i've heard people like
what
you know you get the well actually
culture
but nothing uh nothing huge [ __ ] man
i've tried to get blow
back man i thought i've tried to get
canceled i i thought with cancel culture
i can get
that trader joe's bit some subtraction
again
[ __ ] i did all the accents i love it
you're gonna get fired from sarah live
how about this i do all these accents
your management's like can you do
another accent joke we'll put it on
youtube it'll go viral
oh yeah well not now you gotta put it
because
i mean i had pictures that i was like
put them i'm like here you go
instead of somebody else finding it
finding it this is what i put online my
sister got some kittens like
13 years ago that i just used i've
discovered
microsoft paint or whatever and just
wrote horrible things in these pictures
of
these kittens that i thought were
hilarious because it was so over the top
because it was pictures of kittens
and i put them out like hey this is
something i did
years ago but if you want to cancel me
for it here you go
because at least i'm putting it out
there instead of somebody else like can
you believe he did this i'm like yeah i
did this
nobody cared just racist racist kitten
pictures nobody cared trying to get some
heat
releasing the new album here she's like
i i gotta get canceled so i can get some
downloads
oh you gotta get picked up to get
cancelled i'll play that
well you've got the hot breath bump now
okay you've got the hot breath bump
behind you
so this is what brings me down oh no no
bump up we're bumping
we're bumping here this is a this is
when people finally start to look for
racist kitten pictures
all right this is this is the trampoline
in your ditch this is the trampoline
that's going to propel you
which is the name of your new album hey
look at that segway
sure is sure is good call yeah
but what um yeah is there anything where
will people
be able to get it because we'll release
this we can release it the week of if
you want so we can kind of get momentum
into the actual launch
um yeah one of the details
you know streaming on the streamers uh
it's had
it's kind of coming out again uh new
management has given me a lot of
information like all right it's
exclusive on
sirius this weekend and then next
weekend it's going to be exclusive on
pandora i'm like
i don't understand um july 24th july
24th is when it releases
yeah cool yeah we'll be sure to promote
anything you post about it as well we're
we're
we're here to help we're all about
comedy and helping comics so whatever we
can do hey that's good
well i appreciate it man and is there is
there any
closing advice like for comedians like
your favorite comedy advice you've
gotten or just anything that's always
stuck with you through your career you
could kind of leave us with
uh i my my guarantee like
if you're new or just
anybody focusing on like you know i'll
see like well how do i want to make a
career am i like
no don't ever use the word career
and stand up in the same sentence
if if you're i'd always tell people like
do you love it enough that you'll do it
for free forever
that's how like if you can't say that
sentence
don't don't do comedy like it's
it's a bar sport it's like darts or pool
you can be really good at it and you can
be the best person at darts
in that bar and then maybe you'll get so
good at darts
you'll get to go to other bars and maybe
get free nachos and
free beer to play darts at those bars
but think about how many dart players
pay their bills
from darts it's not a lot
so you just got to be one of those
people who loves playing darts
after work you're going to go to work
you're not going to quit your jobs you
could travel
playing darts for a couple beers in
different bars across the country
maybe maybe you'll get to that but to
start
do you just like going to an open mic
and trying to come up with new material
not do you like doing the same five
minutes every week to get laid
or to get the predictable laughs do you
like going to open mics because you want
to write new stuff
whether you bomb or not you love the
challenge of it
it's it's a puzzle that doesn't get
finished that's what's great about
common
there's no end to it so for people to
think like oh i just need to get the act
and then i'll get all this no no the act
is never done
there's no like however many specials i
have all that is is just
just one movable scale across this is
the material that excited me at this
time now
this is what excited me at this time and
sometimes it overlaps and i've
screwed up by doing a joke from one
special and another one so i don't
listen to anything in the past i just
have rewritten it now it moves over here
so that's
it do you love doing comedy enough that
you're gonna willing to do it for free
forever now that's that's a level of
commitment that
like yeah this is just my hobby that i
i'm lucky enough for right now to make a
living off of
that's some of my favorites goes away
i love it yeah that's my favorite comedy
advice that's the perfect analogy
yeah it's a bar sport yep so listen to
that comedians
remember that so um yeah kyle thank you
so much for doing this i'm gonna hit the
round of applause again
our sound effect here oh we got one at
the buzzer
do you think hannibal burris would do
this show
i cannot speak for hannibal that guy is
he's his own little he's his own planet
he's his own yeah he's his own
weird little planet operating in a solar
system
that is not ours well we'll we'll try to
we'll try to get a tesla roadster over
to him so we'll definitely reach out to
him
um kyle thank you so much for doing this
show man it's been an absolute thrill
everyone's saying
thank you kyle this was awesome very
informative
very nice awesome all right hopper at
the verse
we'll go forth july 24th is when the
album
officially drops go support
kyle trampoline in a ditch if you're
serious about becoming a comedian
join our facebook group linked in the
description below to start getting tips
like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing
today